a soundtrack to describe this process in
the state
it would sound a lot like despacito it's
going very slowly but
authorities here say they're aiming for
accuracy not speed
anthony accuracy is key enrique thank
you very much
senator mcconnell just weighed in on the
vote count on twitter
he writes quote here's how this must
work in our great country
every legal vote should be counted any
illegally submitted ballots must not
all sides met must get to observe the
process
and the courts are here to apply the
laws and resolve disputes
that's how america that's how americans
votes decide the results
and we are joined now by nevada attorney
general aaron ford
attorney general ford good morning
thanks so much for being with us
uh as you just heard as you just heard
enrique say
there are allegations by the trump
campaign they filed a lawsuit claiming
that
some 3 000 improper ballots were filed
have you seen any evidence of voter
fraud in your state
well we have not and nor has our
republican secretary of state barbara
sugaski
nor have our 17 county registrars and in
fact
this six-page complaint that they filed
late last night
is in a word garbage uh when you take a
look at the list that they presented
and they never presented me the list by
the way if you take a look at the list
of folks on that name one of the first
things that pops
out is that there are a lot of military
addresses on that list
uh what that led what their cover letter
says is that it appears as though these
people may have been properly
uh cast mailing ballots that's pure
speculation
uh and as evidenced by the fact that the
list itself has military people on it
it just goes to show the last efforts
that these guys are going to go through
to try to
derail this election campaign yeah as we
we just heard james corden james corden
making some jokes about the
the vote counting in las vegas uh
referring to the fact that
he was right referring to the fact that
the casinos are all open all night so
why can't the vote counting be i know we
want accuracy
but the vote counting does appear to be
going slowly why so slowly
well it's going slowly because this is a
new endeavor for us to be sure
our legislature and its infinite wisdom
decided to mail all mack
have all active voters receive mail in
ballots this year so that they could
exercise a constitutional franchise to
vote
free from coping and most folks took
advantage of that and so it's taken time
to
receive and process these melon ballots
which has built in redundancies to
prevent fraud
uh we have signature verification we
have uh unique barcodes and we have
other redundancies to ensure that we
don't have people who are voting twice
or otherwise and so that's why it's
taken longer and people are not sleeping
i'm not sleeping i can tell you that
and what we're trying to do is to ensure
that we have uh some accurate
results that are laid out based on the
voices that have been raised
through this election cycle do you have
a sense when that when you might have a
final count
well what i do know is that uh there's a
november 12th
deadline by which joe gloria has
indicated obviously he's going to meet
that's the local county registrar
but all of our state registrars have to
meet that deadline i wouldn't be
surprised if it's met before that but
that's not my lane so to speak i do know
that we're going to be getting
results in today as well and we will
have a better picture of
what the results look like at some time
around nine or ten o'clock today
what how significant in in terms of
number of votes do you expect that to be
um well at a minimum of 51 if i fifty
one thousand that's 51 51 000 is what i
recall
uh someone saying on yesterday but again
that's more in the province of our
secretary of state our chief elections
officer
and the local registrars to talk about
that 90 of these votes that are being
tallied are coming out of clark county
which is where las vegas is located
which is
about two-thirds of the state's
population in any event uh and so uh you
know
that that's what we're going to be
seeing tallied and coming out
today at nine and at ten or ten o'clock
this morning all right attorney general
ford thank you so much for joining us
and i hope you get some sleep we
appreciate it
thank you thank you so much i wish that
for all of us
democratic senator that's amy klobuchar
will talk with us a little bit later on
about the presidential race and her
party apparently
falling short way short in its bid to
control